I can't really emphasize enough what
effect Vanessa had on the Little Sisters
of our generation her little sisters the
the actors
and I was talking about astir in LA my
own sister-in-law last week about you
and it's not the first time she's a poet
and an actress and she said well you
know what it is about Vanessa the minute
you saw her you became a devotee and you
determined that you would see everything
she was in and you sort of had to prep
for it if she was going to be in a play
you read the play and if it was going to
be a film you read everything about the
film the director the writer you knew
because she was going to ask something
of you in this way she's going to give
more than anybody else of course but she
also was going to call something up so
you had to kind of be ready emotionally
and intellectually and even even
spiritually because something was going
to be asked of you and that's so rare
and it it's addictive so we watched
everything you were in I was in my first
film Julie I was 27 and I didn't have
any scenes with Vanessa all my scenes
were with Jane who showed me what a mark
was and how to hit it and how if you
didn't
sighs you're looking rightful to Jane
although I had two scenes in the movie
they caught one and they put the scenes
from the foot one that was cut into my
mouth for the second scene so it's like
the worst debut
I think anybody's ever made and I never
got to work with you Vanessa but I got
to share of the car with you and I was
27 I was right out of drama school a
year out and I thought well I said where
would I go say her cuz we share we went
back and forth and I was just completely
tongue-tied but it just didn't matter
because the minute you got into the car
you did all the talking from the time we
got into the car the time he got out and
it was all about politics and things
about Trotsky I didn't know anything
about Trotsky I mean I was really dim I
admit it and um you know concentrating
on my hair in the movie was important
but it wasn't so I never I never made
the connection with you that I dreamed
of making with my goddess and until of
course I saw Julia and when I saw Julia
I mean that scene that scene is
absolutely astonishing really really
amazing and I really I remember having
the same I haven't seen it since the
first time I saw it and I went to the
movie thinking it's my first movie it's
my first me I can t remember me in the
movie
and this scene was so incredibly
intimate and it made me think of the
privilege we have as actors that we do
get to love each other that's what we
get paid for which is just remarkable
'he's like prostitutes or something we
get we get paid to feel what and express
what people can't in their normal lives
I did get to act with you in a real
scene in a movie in evening uh and we
and I was because it was a real proper
scene and I was so grateful for that
chance we just had the one scene I had
the one day and was nervous again and we
played very very old friends
and you were very ill and I came back
from your past to see you and in a very
short time space of a little scene we
cover pretty much all the things that I
want to say to you so you say no I say I
never expected as much as you did and
you say I expected so much yes I said
you did and you got so much my god
you were wonderful standing up there so
beautiful
so strong and brave so full of hope oh
she's nothing you said well it was
something to me I think about it
I still think about it that's the scene
I mean what else can I say to you I love
you and I thank you for a lifetime of
inspiration and I want you to keep it up
because we all speaking on behalf of the
group needed
you